police in Farmington New Mexico say an
18-year-old male opened fire with at
least three different weapons including
an AR style rifle shooting off about 50
shifts though going on possibly one
patient still laying in the middle of
the road it appears to be purely random
farmington's police chief posted a video
to Facebook saying the shooter's motive
is still under investigation there were
schools no churches no individual is
targeted once police arrived four
officers confronted the suspect seeing
pacing back and forth in this video
that's when more gunfire erupted
I'm watching a guy shoot at the cops
with an extended clip right now after
several rounds were exchanged the
suspect was declared dead and two
officers were injured in total police
say the shooter killed three people and
heard six others